Let me welcome all of you on
behalf of MIT, on behalf of
the Office of Educational
Innovation and Technology, and
on behalf of our partners here,
Apple, Scott's, I don't
know, it's not always good to
extend the family metaphor
because of all the intended
dysfunctionality, but, you
know, it's like a member of an
extended family over here.
But, really, we welcome you
to MIT and to this event.
There is a lot of planning,
I know.
Not just what Scott was talking
about, I watched
Andrew, who works in our office,
along with Jeff and
Judy go at it you know,
for quite some time.
So it's a treat to have you
over here and to have this
event over here.
I'm not going to be talking
about OEIT today, although the
Office of Educational Innovation
and Technology,
although, you know, I'm hoping
to touch on some examples, as
they are relevant to
my conversation.
I should also apologize to you
in advance, I'm not doing to
be singing for you today.
My voice is a little bit off,
but I do hope to talk about
some things open, and really
about this gathering storm,
you know, which I call the open
education movement, and
the potentially implications
it has for
transforming education.
And you know, it was really
about, I don't know if it was
at 2:00 in the morning today or
7:00 in the morning today.
You know I got onto MIT's web
page, and this was the page,
and I said wow!
You know, somebody paid somebody
to do this, because
it really epitomizes at least
certainly the institutional
commitment part of openness that
we want to talk about.
Last week at the faculty
meeting, not in this room,
some faculty meetings are held
in this room, but in another
renovated space in the main
drag, MIT faculty wanted to
provide, you know, to allow the
institute to provide open
access to all scholarly
articles, which sort of shows
the commitment and, of course,
most of you have heard about
OpenCourseWare, which was the
educational version of this.
So there's, you know, so there's
some institutional
teeth to this movement,
certainly as far as we are
concerned here at MIT.
So, having -- let me pop it up
there and -- so, I chose an
old expression to describe a new
phenomenon, you know the
new deal, only to signify the
tremendous opportunity that I
see, this open education
movement has, and, you know,
it's characterized by open
content, open knowledge, open
technology and all these
dimensions sort of describe
the envelope of the open
education movement.
And the top part, you know, in
this world of borrowing and
collaboration euphemistically
called match ups, actually
borrowed the top part of that,
advancing the educational life
of information resources of
title from a guru of mine,
John Seely Brown, who many of
you know had this social life
of information.
The thesis there being that
the community really gives
meaning to information.
And here, my pitch is that a lot
of what openness is about
is breathing educational life
into information resources
which are becoming available and
plenty, through, you know,
through the kinds of initiatives
that I'm going to
talk about.
So the promise was best
articulated by Chuck Vest, who
was President here at MIT, who
is now the President of the
National Academy, National
Academy for Engineering, and
it was under his championship,
actually, that OpenCourseWare
at MIT was launched.
And Fred painted this,
you know, this
vision, if you will.
And he said we are talking about
OpenCourseWare and the
surrounding initiatives that
were sprouting at that time,
to say we are seeing the early
emergence of a Metaversity.
A transcendent, accessible,
empowering, dynamic community
constructed framework of open
materials and platforms, on
which much of higher education
worldwide can be constructed
or enhanced.
And it's a tremendous vision.
It is a vision of
the Metaversity.
And what I am contending today
is that much of what you have
seen, remarkable as it is, the
OpenCourseWare as a movement,
and I'll point to some of the
evidence, is the first phase
off that vision.
It is Metaversity part one, and
the kinds of things that
we are all engaged in really
points to a deeper vision of
this second phase, which is
more akin to what I think
Chuck is trying to describe
over there, the
Metaversity part two.
So, very quickly, some off the
artifacts some off the
evidence of this gathering storm
that I refer to are some
of the things that categorize
the Metaversity part one.
Of course, we like to start
with OpenCourseWare.
Around 2000, when MIT very
boldly, and some of us thought
at that time thought rationally,
announced that it
would make the content of all
its courses available on the
web for free to the world.
And I remember being in the
room, as part of the Counsel
in Education Technology when
the sub-group came back and
said, you know, maybe
we should do this.
And there were two remarkable
things that
happened, that are true.
One was our emotional
response.
We said, whoa -- this is big,
you know, and, which was
tremendous.
We all knew this was something
very important.
The second thing was none
of us knew what
it meant, you know.
So, we said, well, but
it was powerful.
None of us really understood the
profound implications that
have subsequently emerged
from that announcement.
Of course, one of the side
benefits, and then since then
lots has happened, you know.
A couple of Octobers ago MIT,
all of MIT's 1,800 courses
were actually made available
through OpenCourseWare, and --
which is tremendous, which is
sort of -- you know, the first
item was Daily Word, and the
first part of the promise was
Daily Word.
Now, one side benefit that I
always like to point out from
OpenCourseWare is that we like
to say to MIT that we figured
out actually how many courses
there were, indeed, at MIT.
So we, you know, because we said
all the courses, like in
the old days we used to talk
about the Athena computing
environment.
It was sort of everything, but
we didn't exactly what it was,
and 1,800 was a good number,
so that's where it come.
So that was there, but the
interesting thing about the
open education movement that
I'm referring to was
certainly, motivated, led,
catalyzed by OpenCourseWare,
but that's not the movement,
and it's not even, when we
announced OpenCourseWare, it
was interesting because the
kinds of letters we'd get from
all over the world, MIT used
to get, and typically in
presentations, and in fact, if
you go to the MIT OpenCourseWare
site, you will
see stats on the millions off
hits and how much access, and
that's all wonderful.
That's great data.
That's great information, but
the impact data is really
vignette like this, when you
talk about the fact that when
you put out resources like
OpenCourseWare, people can use
it for curriculum formulation
elsewhere.
It serves as a model and so it's
not just about consuming
the content that is put over
there, but being able to learn
from it the way it is put
together, the way it is
structured in order that you
can do your own thing more
efficiently.
So this is, Richard Hall, who
says it saved him an enormous
amount of time and stress.
I could use some
of that myself.
So, the other kind of vignette,
which I look at as
evidence is this one, where,
you know, you actually have
students elsewhere who are using
this, and who actually
go and look at the notes in
OpenCourseWare and then use
them as supplements to what
they're learning.
And by the way, this is a
phenomenon that I experience
all the time when I'm giving
talks, for instance, in India,
I'd be there giving a talk to
you know, some 1,700 people in
a class like this, and I'll as
for a show of hands, how many
of you have heard of OCW, you
know, the hands will go up.
Then I'll ask, how many
of you use OCW?
And what is remarkable is that
there are classes where all
the students would have their
hands up, you know.
And unselfconsciously, with
the instructor over there,
because they using get
the supplements.
Sometimes they're looking at it
as a benchmark, to ask an
instructor why isn't our course
looking like that, or
why aren't we covering those
aspects of the content?
So you can start to see the
kinds of implications of
things open.
It is not just about
being able to go
and grab the contents.
It serves as a model.
It serves as a benchmark.
It serves as a mirror into your
quality, and this is,
these are the --
I'm trying to start giving you
hints of the transubmitive
impact of things open.
Again, but that's is
not the movement.
This was, so far I've
talked about OCW.
What characterized the movement
was, now actually
hundreds of OCWs that started.
There's a consortium with
160 institutions.
Brandon, sitting over there,
is actually involved in the
consortium, as I am.
So the number of universities
who started making there
materials available, and number
of initiatives that
started making their resources
available in one form or the
other, making them available
for consumption across the
world for free.
So that characterizes the scale
of the movement, and why
I use terms like a gatherings
storm, because this is big.
I go to the Commonwealth of
Learning meetings in London,
and they say, well you know,
we have to have OER as a
strategy for extensive access
to education in developing
countries, you know.
And why they are able to make
statements like that is
because they see the evidence
of the movement in pretty
dramatically ways.
So that's one part.
I mention the consortium.
Now, typically we think this is
all about higher education.
Not true, you know.
There are very significant K
through 12 initiatives, some
of which you see listed
before you.
One that Scott mentioned
in my introduction.
Curriki which I served as
adviser to, which actually
came out of Scott McNealy's
championship from Sun
Microsystems, but this is, the
Curriki initiative is to make
sure that you can create a
framework so that people can
contribute resources for K
through 12, and then make it
widely available in an
open-fashion and open-source
model, and mapping it to
regional, local and curricula,
not just in this country,
but elsewhere.
So in the K through 12 domain
also there is a palpable
movement, open movement, and
you know, with some good
materials, people say, well
you know, if it's open, it
won't be good.
It's all bitter medicine
thing.
And there are some very, very
good pieces off educational
courseware, you know, applets
if you will, to teach
different concepts.
And this contribution from
around the world, there are
initiatives that have been
launched, to filter, to make
sure there is good, appropriate
content.
MIT itself has provided a
channel to its OpenCourseWare
for, you know, for
higher education.
We call it highlights for high
school, where you provide
particular channels into courses
and content which
might be relevant for high
school consumption, for
advanced placement of, you know,
of advanced preparation.
This is a resource that I
like to point to in the
K through 12 domain.
This was an initiative that was
launch by Carl Wyman, no
less, who was the year before
last, Novel Laureate in
physics, and he had launched
this when he was at the
University of Colorado.
And, where, if you go to this
site, and now of course, Carl
has moved on to University of
British Columbia, and this
site is there.
It is maintained by his group.
It is openly, maid
openly available.
And if you go to the site, you
will find that there is very,
you know, there'll be statements
about how the
resources over there have
been evaluated.
There has been very, very good,
you know, they have
founded, they have been
developed on very, very good
educational principles.
There has been some amount of
vigorous evaluation done.
All this to tell you that there
is open stuff there,
good stuff that, there is
quality stuff there, capable
off making great transformative
contribution to
education as we know it.
And what happens is, over time,
when you start doing
these things, the kind of sort
of vision that Scott was
alluding to, you start
seeing pieces of.
But like I said, that's all
fantastic, but it's still --
I characterize all that
as F part one.
Part two, I think, is when, and
if you've noticed, many of
those are about fantastic
resources, largely about
content, and they are
stand-alone, they are
disparitary resources, but
transformative impact or
systemic change, I think, for
education, happens when we can
move from there to another kind
of place where we can
actually provide quality end to
an educational experience
through things open.
So when we think about
end-to-end educational
experiences, we think not only
about content, but how we
might be able to do, provide
first-hand experiences,
laboratory experiences, as, you
know, to complement good
content out there.
How might we provide good
interactive experiences for
people learning and how we
might actually harvest
resources that might be
available anywhere and
productivity combine them to
deliver different kinds of
learning experiences to suit
different audiences.
And, really keep the focus on
quality, the fact that you can
generate new kinds
of experiences,
new kinds of material.
So what I'd like to do now is
just point to some off the
kinds of initiatives, and I will
apologize, many of the
initiatives that I'm pointing
to are MIT based, but you
know, I talk about what
I know better.
So I'll point to them,
but they're done.
And I'll also point out that
they might have been launched
at MIT, but right from the
get-go they involved other
institutions, other players.
But they speak to the kinds
of, the value proposition
elements that I think will take
us to to this vision of a
Metaversity II.
So, this is an initiative that
I like to talk about a lot.
On the left is Jesus del Alamo
he is a professor right here,
upstairs, teaches in electrical
engineering.
So some years ago, he started
this thing called iLab and the
intent of iLab is to provide
access to real laboratories
over the internet, not
simulations, actually labs.
So, initially it started off
with some, you know, network
signal analyzer and for digital
signal processing courses.
And then there were some other
labs that actually got
launched, and we had students
from Singapore, from Sweden
sort of places who
were actually
conducting labs over here.
And, you know, then we had some
of our Cambridge students
actually looking at, you know,
we had a partnership with the
University of Cambridge,
who was
looking at chemical reactors.
There was a civil engineering, a
shake table experiment to do
seismic measurements, and
these work controlled,
accessed, through browsers, and
people actually adjusted
the parameters, saw the results,
and not only that,
there were communities swarming
which would discuss
the results.
And in fact, we have one that is
going on right now, an NSF
supported project where K
through 12 students have
browser-based access.
MIT has a benign, friendly,
nuclear reactor.
I have to put all these
qualifiers over there, but you
know, it's provides
access to those.
And you can see, I mean you can
imagine the empowerment
when K through 12 students are
watching these neutrons go,
and by the way, the same
browser-based access that is
providing data for spectrometry
experiments to a
nuclear engineering program,
but the fact is that iLabs,
the technical architecture,
the framework iLabs, makes
labs available, labs accessible
openly over the internet.
So that's brings a first-time,
hands-on experience to
complement open resources
that might be
available in a course.
Now, so you can see, and I
normally talk about this more
than I should, but I'm really
passionate about this.
Because, one of the things that
you find that happens,
and this is a transformative
dimension of this, is that
iLabs is not just about making
expensive equipment, you know,
a radio telescope accessible
to people, you know, but it
really alters the economics
of lab instruction.
Labs are expensive,
whether they're
small labs or big labs.
You configure them.
They take time to
be configured.
They are one-time
installation.
You set it up.
You do it.
Then you've got to wait long
time before you set up again.
There's always latency.
I do not know about your
education, but you know,
Monday you got the lecture.
And a couple of weeks later
you did the lab work
or didn't do it.
Solid latency between when you
learned the concept and you
would actually be able
to learn from it.
So it was expensive, you know,
what IT affrays, it was
expensive in terms of
the learner's time.
It was expensive in terms of
the fact that there were
one-time installation, and
suddenly this iLab project
provides the potential to say,
you know, this 24 by 7 access
for this, being able to leverage
a setup much more
extensively, can dramatically
alter the economics of
laboratory instruction.
That is, of course, if you
believe as we do, that
laboratory instruction,
first-hand experiences are a
very important part off the
educational experience.
And you know, there are things
that, we had students here for
one time, I remember, who wanted
to do some experiments
with Compaq's clean labs.
We, Compaq didn't want our
student traipsing all over the
clean labs over there, but the
setup allowed us to do
controlled experiments
in the clean labs.
So you can start imagining the
implications, not only for
formal education, but things
like vocational education,
cannot connect up with equipment
that might be
available industry.
So it has the potential to
dramatically alter the economics.
Now, again, the interesting
things about iLab and open
iLabs is not the five or six or
seven labs that have been
set up at MIT and being made
accessible, but the fact that
there are labs elsewhere, in
fact, both at the University
of Queensland our colleague,
Phil Hong, who's there.
University of Queensland, China,
they have more labs in
the iLab framework than
actually MIT has.
And so the architecture allows
lab anywhere to be set up.
In fact, for us, the value
proposition is that we might
want our students to
access labs that
have been set up elsewhere.
So that's the value proposition,
and that's where
the openness dimension comes the
open architecture, allows
people to set up labs, big or
small, and make it accessible
to students all over
the world.
So, I'm pointing to a
couple of things.
This is done at our office, at
the Office of Educational
Innovation and Technology.
The day before yesterday, Chuck
Schubert, who heads this
group called the Star Group,
at, oh yes, he came and you
know, had me sign a few forms,
a whole bunch of the Star
tools for visualization in
biology, in genetic modeling
for genetic modeling for
hydrology, that had been set
up, are now an open source
and made available.
So these are fantastic
simulations.
And why I'm pointing to these
particular ones, because there
is educational, because they
are tied to some very good
deep thinking about tools that
are available openly, and you
know, there are great
visualization tools tools, and
we've all seen them.
They are common.
This is part of a program that
we have at OEIT to bridge
research and learning, to
bring, to provide our
undergraduate students,
first-year students, with
early exposure to research
tools, and the kinds of
applications that typically
are only available to
researchers.
And how can we remove the
operational fog from these, so
that first-year students, again
in this case even K
through 12 students, can
actually use these tools.
This visualization that is seen
which looks like Justin,
who also works with us,
twirling, you know, when they
are visualizing DNA molecules,
students look at it, They make
conjectures about
it's properties.
They can reach into Cornell's
protein database, make
comparisons now, and so you
provide some very empowering
experiences and exposure to very
big professional tools
and profession thinking, and
provide them the confidence by
creating visualizations
like this, with
students can control.
Now these kinds of simulations
of tools are available in the
open, and what lies under them
is a lot of good thinking,
hard problems that certainly are
a faculty of experience,
in bringing research concepts
into learning, because it's
all nice to say, you know, we
want to have lots of proximity
between research and teaching,
but to create tangible,
manageable crosswalks is not
easy, and you do it through
these tools, and then you make
these tools widely available
so that students all over
can benefit from it.
So, I'm trying to give you
a sense of the kinds of
possibilities, the enablements
that lead to this vision, this
vision that is more advanced
than the current capabilities
that open resources
have created.
Now this is a project, this is
very dear to my friend, Andrew
over there, and he and his team,
and Brandon, they are
all working on this.
This is a project that was
started by a professor
upstairs, a Professor Jim Glass
in Computer Science, and
what it does is it uses natural
language recognition,
voice recognition,
summarization.
And the intent is to provide
very, very acute and good
access to digitized content.
So we have digital video of
lectures and the idea is to go
search these to get particular
snippets of the lectures that
might be relevant.
So, for instance, what you can't
see, probably seen in
the highlight, there's
a lot of angular
momentum showing up.
So what we are working on is to
make sure that you can use
this to go and find all those
lecture segments that deal
with angular momentum, because
if I as an instructor, want to
provide some deeper thinking,
a nuance learning around the
notion of angular momentum, I
want to be able to make sure
the students can get efficiently
to that section,
because you know, it might occur
all over the place in
the course of a lecture or in
the course of a 14-week
semester, where this topic might
be treated in different
ways, and you want students to
go very, very efficiently to
those segments and get there.
So the Spoken Lecture Browser
provides very, very -- as it's
named -- browser-based access,
and, but it uses, like I said,
natural language recognition
to get there.
This is a very exciting project,
and what we are
trying to do is see how this
can be really leveraged not
only for video content across
our courses, Andrew and team
are working on a couple of
introductory physics courses.
Some off you might have seen
this dramatic video lecture,
Walter Lewin's lecture
on OpenCourseWare.
He has been featured
on everything
from Jay Leno to NPR.
But, you know, you can get to
segments of Lewin's lecture,
and they're working on that,
because a current instructor,
Peter Dourmashkin, wants his
students to go to particular
concepts, you know, advanced
learning and particular
things, and the spoken lecture,
you know, at OEIT, we
are stabilizing the research
work in the project and
enabling that kind
of research.
Our goal is to take it to open
video content that might be
available across, you know, from
different institutions,
at least as a start for all of
the universities that are in
the OpenCourseWare consortium.
So that's, you can see that
kind of enablement, again,
extending that to, this is a
wonderful project, Shakespeare
in Asia, which has got various
renderings of Shakespeare
presentations, video
presentations, and the idea is
to do the same spoken
lecture browser kind
of access to this.
Those of you who thought
Shakespeare was deal, he is
just living under an assumed
name, and so, but there's --
but this is yet another -- and
I'm showing you these to, let
me give you the sub-text
over here.
The idea of these is, see, that
in order to realize the
next stage of educational
transformation through open
resources, we not only need
the surround off active
experience, we also need the
means to go collectively
harvest in useful educational
content very, very easily.
We want to reduce the barriers
to get to them, and I keep
using the word productively,
because you just don't want to
see and not touch, you want to
see, bring, use, and use in
the fashion that you want.
So, how do you productively
combine them?
Now this was a wonderful
project which sort of
demonstrates that, and it was
built on OKI's open service
interface definition, the
service interfaces.
And this was, Shigeru Miyagawa,
who is the professor
in Linguistics, actually over
here, and he and John Dower,
who is a prize winning, Pulitzer
winning historian,
they created this program called
Visualizing Cultures,
by the way, this is an
OpenCourseWare also.
And it goes, the intent was to
teach history and culture,
expose students to Japanese
history and
culture, through images.
Images that are available in a
variety of repositories, some
in Japan, some of the Museum
of Fine Arts over here.
And the idea was to go, be
able to get these through
different kinds of
applications.
And you know, these images
are fantastic.
For instance, some of them,
which have to do with
Commodore Perry's trips to
Japan, and if you look at them
there's a whole city called
Black Ships and Samurai, now
that you see on top.
And it's very interesting,
because depending on the
relationship that the US had
with Japan, people in Japan
would depict Commodore Perry.
So sometimes you see him
characterized as a nice,
beaming, benevolent fellow,
and sometimes you see him
drawn like an ogre.
And, you know, it's reflective
of the kinds of, the political
dynamics if you will,
of that period.
But anyway, that's
the content part.
The message here for me, from
this slide, which has to do
with materials from Doc
Edgerton, who was the creator
of strobe photography, who
has, you know, wonderful
archive of materials.
It's to say that we want to be
able to say there are good
qualities of resources, rich
media resources out there, and
we want to be able to really
lower the barrier to getting
to these, and getting to
these through different
applications.
For instance, here you're
seeing, and this is a
three-year old slide, four-year
old slide, here you
are seeing those images that
Shigeru was using for
visualizing cultures, got
through Harvestrodes Hive.
Hive was a Java-based
application.
We had to get to content
from repositories.
You're seeing it accessed
through our course management
system, through a search tool
for the images in our course
management system
on the right.
You're seeing it accessed
through the visual
understanding editor, a
concept tool the Tufts
University created.
So here the idea is that you
can have these, you know,
wonderful depositories of rich
content to do good things
educationally, but you want to
bring them together, make them
accessible through OEIT
of open or proprietary
applications.
And that's the kind of
econological transformation
that we think will lead to the,
at least I believe will
lead to this Metaversity
vision.
So, and you created, you know,
you, so, the message that we
hear, it's not just about all
the resources that are being
created openly, but the
technological enablements, and
then as I will point out in
a bit, the organizational
enablements that will
allow us to approach
that kind of vision.
So, a lot of the stuff that I
showed you was about deep
learning, subjects and stuff.
The message of open and
transformation is
much bigger than that.
This is also, this is not just
about innovation at a
micro-level, and significant
as it is, it's not about
changing courses or even
changing universities, it is
also about national crusades.
Scott mention that I had the
opportunity to serve as an
advisor to India's National
Knowledge Commission.
India, as most of you know, is
a country in a hurry, you
know, to play in the national,
in the knowledge economy.
And some years ago, you know,
the National Knowledge
Commission was formed by the
Prime Minister to say, how can
we really scale excellence,
provide quality it the scales.
To meet the needs off this
explosive economy?
We need knowledge workers
to build roads, to build
hospitals, to build up,
you know, engineering
institutions.
We need doctors, and how can we
provide quality education
at scale, and knowing what I
know about the numbers, you
cannot do it in the
traditional way.
Not, you can't do it in the
traditional way you can't
build schools I mean I could
give you statistics, 55
million kids who come
out of primary
education, no place to go.
Even if you built a school a
week, it would not be able to
meet the demand.
There are about 11 institutions
in the Institute
of Technology you could keep,
and they are being added on.
The message is that what the
open education movement offers
is a way of going and being able
to provide that kind of
quality education at
scale efficiently.
And, therefore, a whole set of
recommendations were made
which are being acted upon,
which have been accepted.
They are part of the Planning
Commission team entirely based
on open education resources,
and again, the model over
here, and this is a real, a very
short-time caricature of
the recommendations that
I'm presenting to you.
Essentially, to say that, you
know, you can have distributed
depositories of fantastic
content.
You can have a very good
technical substrate, which
allows and good applications,
which allows people to harvest
these, and be able to deliver
education to meet the needs of
various sectors.
Again, in a scalable and
efficient fashion.
And actually, this particular
slide is because in order to
show that this is not just
a pipe dream, we actually
started building small
applications to show it.
I saw Jeff had just walked in,
Jeff Merrimen, he and I and
some off you might know Stuart
Sim, we actually we're working
with this group called IUCE,
there's an Indo-U.S.
collaboration on engineering
education, and the model was
to see how faculty over here
could, and there, could go get
content from radius open
initiatives from MIT's
OpenCourseWare.
India has put a lot of its
engineering content, there's
an initiative called NPTEL,
The National Program on
Technology Enabled Learning,
which has put out about 120 --
I mean it's significant.
All the engineering courses
available through You Tube,
and so what we worked on
was trying to develop a
demonstration which would allow
faculty to get content
from OCW, from NPTEL from Rice
University's connections, and
create courses along with the
collaborative surround, you
know we keep it surround,
so that they actually
collaborate, construct
the courses
from various resources.
So that's the value
proposition.
If you look at what I have, when
I talk about Metaversity
two, the elements of the open
movement that it really draws
upon is aid that you can have
large, sort of unprecedented
volume of quality resources,
which are available anywhere,
anytime, you know, through
the kinds of
enablements I described.
What's more, because of the
way they are constructed,
because, and the kinds of
information that surrounds
them, they can actually
be localized.
And you know, I personally am a
very big believer, you know,
we keep talking about education
being a cottage
industry, as if it was
something bad.
I actually believe that it
derives its value from being a
cottage industry, and part of
the challenge that we face is
how can we really make that
cottage industry thrive
efficiency?
And when I say cottage industry,
it means that a lot
of value is derived locally, and
we need to -- the idea of,
one of the things that the
open education resource
movement offers is that you can
have large pools of shared
resources, without militating
against the localization that
is very important for good
education to happen.
It provides alternatives, you
know, deeper learning, and I
will some examples.
One of the things that it does
allow, and this is not in my
slides, but I will make
a quick mention.
It does allow a lot
of feedback.
When we talk about educational
transformation, it's not just
about access and good tools,
but what is the generated
mechanism that you
have in order to
improve on what you do?
Now, I remember when
OpenCourseWare was launched,
Shigeru, whom I refer to, now
it's visualizing cultures, he
had a wonderful statement out
there on our website, the OCW
websites, which said that, you
know, this is about we, as
educators, we know how to share
our research, but we
don't know how to share our
pedagogy for critical review.
Now, if you think about it for
a second, what you really do
through OpenCourseWare
is you say, look,
this is how we teach.
Have at it.
Tell us what you can do.
So that's, and if you can have
the means to incorporate that
feedback that people might give
you into continuously
improving your courses, good
things can happen.
And there's a very good
demonstration of this.
Carnegie Mellon has set up this
thing called, they have
this initiative called the Open
Learning Initiative, OLI,
and there's a statistics
course where they have
created, which allows the
community to give feedback,
and then that's incorporated
into the into the course
segments themselves, and what
they've found was that they
had a learning gain of 50% in
the delivery of the statistics
course, and I'll tell
you what that means.
What it means is that coverage,
which they would
have had, and without
sacrificing quality, the time
to deliver that course was, for
the same learning games,
was decreased by 50%.
Now that is significant.
That is transubmitive, and we
are not, and this is well
written about.
In fact, Candice [? Till ?]
still has written about this
in the book, that we,
according to, that Scott
was referring to.
So there's this dimension of
collected improvement and
feedback, both at the micro
level and at the macro level
that is really, really important
when you think about
transformation that's afforded
by open education.
So all that's fine.
When I think about possibility
as a signal, there are two
dimensions that are really
important that we all talk
about, which are enabled
by this.
One which I loosely call
blended learning
opportunities.
And what openness allows is
really, and this again speaks
to the context of setting
statements that Scott was
making allows us to really
look at possibilities for
intelligently combining the
physical and the virtual.
How we might, you know, the
highlight example for this,
how might we combine what we
know as good practices and
situated learning, the kinds
of authentic learning
experiences that we provide
in this situation.
The labs, with what
might be digitally
available, online available.
So it purely provides
opportunities to mix and melt
the best of good worlds, and
to be able to localize it.
And this is being done.
This is not something that came
out of some lazy exercise
in -- what shall I say, on
controlled substances.
This is the kind of stuff that
has been practiced, developed,
and demonstrated you know,
through things like iLabs that
I'm talking about, and we have
to start looking at these for
transformation.
You know, the combining the
formal and the non-formal
here, for instance, we are
thinking, how can we use
co-curricular experiences and
combine them with, you know,
as good substitutes for
authentic learning
experiences.
These are the enablements of
open, given the very generous
definition of open that I
provided here, you know, about
open technology, open content,
and open knowledge.
The other really value element,
value vision element
for me is boundary-less
education.
And again, this is not about
traditional boundaries,
geopolitical boundaries, some of
which is true, like in the
IUCEE example I gave, but
even boundaries between
disciplines.
If you go to the OpenCourseWare
site, you will
see some new programs that have
been launched for energy
studies, right?
And these are being possible,
made possible, some of these
boundaries are diminishing our
ability to leverage, content
is happening, because the
substance of the component
courses are becoming visible,
and people are being able to
see much more finely where there
might be substitutions,
where there might be
opportunities to have
compounds of these courses to
lead to new programs that
transcend disciplinary
boundaries or department
boundaries.
I could give you other examples
with there is
boundary-less-ness being
experienced where the boundary
between research learnings and
the lay person is being
diminished.
Neeru Paharia, she's is of the
Graduate Business School over
here at Harvard.
She used to be Director of
Creative Commons, so she has
worked on something called
Acawiki, A C A W I K I, where
actually people go in and
provide sense-making documents
for the lay people, you and I,
who fund research, to have, to
understand research, again, to
take away the divide between,
to diminish the divide between
research and lay people.
So there's a lot of
boundary-less-ness that can
being enabled through
openness.
So I'm going to start, this is
my, sort of getting to my
closing statements over here.
We have this movement, and you
say, well, you know, here's
this guy, he's talking about
all these wonderful
possibilities, and like I said,
you know, this is not a
pipe dream.
How do we interpret pipe, b but
it's born out of really
looking at some markers, some of
the significant influences
that are around us, that
give me comfort,
give me solid hope.
You know, and some of it is
because many of us in this
room are invested and engaged
in these initiatives.
So one significant category of
significant influence I've
already talked a lot about, is
the fact that there's a lot of
open content, there is
good open technology
initiatives going on.
Good design, and I mean this
both in terms of organization
and technology.
I particularly like to talk
about my pet initiative, the
open knowledge initiative, which
allows this kind of, you
know, Scott referred to it as
disaggregation, which allows
different players, different
qualities, different
strengths to play.
So, there are design enablers,
and design is a very important
consideration.
But there are legal enablers,
creative commons, for
instance, which, you know, so
which give me hope that this
vision of Metaversity
II is, indeed,
realizable and can be reaffied.
But there are two dimensions
which I have not touch upon
which I'll quickly tell you.
One is institutional
commitment.
And some of the institutional
commitment is expressed
through communities that
are being created.
The Sakai community, consortia
around iLabs
that are being built.
The groups that meet
around OKI.
So these are expressions of
institutional commitment
around things open that are
forming, which so which are
really becoming the building
blocks for this
open education movement.
There is another kind, which I
really pointed to, and I had a
bunch of slides, and I think
they got finished by today's
web page from MIT that I showed
you, which is a real
expression of MIT commitment.
The slides I was going to show
you, which are really, have to
do with the fact that MIT
expressed its initial, its
institutional commitment to
OpenCourseWare through a lot a
strategic thinking that
preceded the launch of
OpenCourseWare, it's current
commitment to it, right?
And to openness, as expressed
wonderfully by, you know, by
today's web page.
And there is a second dimension
off this, there is
another aspect which is on the
collectivity culture, and you
see that, you know, through
the Wikis, the blogs, the
distributed culture, all the
tools and artifacts of the
digital natives that Scott
was talking about.
So very quickly, some things
about MIT's institutional
commitments.
Like I said, OpenCourseWare
was preceded by a lot of
strategic thinking.
You know, we had this Counsel
on Education Technology, and
there was a particular strategic
thrust around
bolstering the commons off
the mind, you know.
Nice words chosen by Hal
Abelson, who was, you know,
who was a leader in education
technology over here at MIT.
And we had a lot of strategies
around active learning, which
led to all kinds of initiatives
like, you know,
TEAL and iLab and so on.
But the strategy around
intellectual commons was what
was an expression of MIT's
institutional commitment to
things open.
In fact, at that time, and these
slides are dated, you
know, they're circa 2004, but
these initiatives that were
launched were part of an
institutional strategy and the
present MIT's commitment.
This base, which is a very, very
big base, to the website
announcement that you saw about
open access to research,
OKI that you've heard about,
OpenCourseWare that I need not
speak about.
So, the institutional commitment
was because it was
seen as important elements of
educational strategy at MIT.
Now, the second thing about the
collectivity culture, and
I'm going to close over here,
the collectivity culture is
really expressed through, you
know, through what we see.
And my boss, Dan Hastings,
who's the Dean of
Undergraduate Education over
here, has sent us these slides
sometime ago.
And for me, they tells the
story about the digital
natives, and the collectivity
culture, which I think gives
me comfort that -- well, on the
one hand it makes it very
important that we continue to
march on, on this road towards
Metaversity two, but at the same
time it gives me comfort
that it's well on it's way
to being reaffied.
So here are a set of slides
that Dan gave that I think
speak to the collectivity
culture.
This is by a group of students
who fancy that they work at
NASA, and who also asking why
aren't we working at NASA.
And they are --
I won't say much why
it is being played,
they are from gen-Y.
Gen-Y is, by the way, it is
characterized by everyone
between 14 and they say 40,
but I'm going to say 50s.
So and well, these are the,
and you're seeing
characteristics of
this collectivity
generations, right?
So they're talking about why are
-- it's self-explanatory.
Now, there are tools that they,
and this speaks exactly
to your point, By the way,
this is just a sort of
disclaimer slide to say that
NASA actually uses a lot of
these tools.
I think I have said enough.
I hope I have given
you a message.
Thank you very much, and
I hope the message off
everything open is clear.
And I don't know, Scott, if
you wanted to take any
questions, or if -- what have
you noticed, but thanks a lot.